well season 13 is finally here and you
guys
are officially rue girls how does
that feel oh my god so good
it's nuts you watched your show for so
many years what 13 years now and
finally being on it it is an automatic
experience
this is crazy this show's been going for
a decade plus
the rue girls are an institution at this
point and i know each of you has to know
some of these ru girls what advice did
you get before you got to compete
gigi told me she gave me two bits of
advice she said you
have to go in there with all types you
are the best singer you are the best
actress you are the best
uh dancer uh you can do gymnastics if
they tell you [ __ ] you are the best at
everything going there where there's
some sense of delusion
and then also have fun she is here to
play
in the sleigh i was told by coco
montrese
and alexis matteo don't tell anybody
right off the bat what your strengths
are
because it will always be a setup what's
happening
the advice that helped me the most too
was definitely that
like don't give up what anyone else is
doing at all times
who gave you that advice that was kind
of like advice across the board that
i've gotten i've
i've gotten really close with detox and
laganja for a long time and especially
laganja who went through it on her
season i feel like a lot of
that advice yeah i think she learned
that the most and so
i feel like she definitely was hammering
that little number in my head i feel
very attacked
i'm from chicago and i'm really close
with a lot of the chicago girls
and i think it was naomi small she was
like just make sure
you get a wig line that's really super
plush so you
have on tv gary allstar's answers but
shea as well shay gave me a lot of great
advice go on there and be adaptable
because
anything can be thrown at you and you
have to be a chameleon so that was
definitely the best advice i've ever
seen
i received a lot of advice and there is
one thing that was outstanding
uh in in the the book of advice i
received and it was from
uh jiggly caliente she said girl
get a good beard cover
and i did very practical advice
very practical yeah elena doesn't have a
lot of the girls that have been on there
so
i was on my own i had to figure it out
for myself take a look around honey you
got some competition
where the best advice i got from bianca
was treated like a business
even though it's you know like your life
or our
life trixie and i are both from
milwaukee and she said you know like
you're a performer
you're a lip thinker they're going to
eat you up they're going to love it just
like enjoy the ride and be yourself
don't try to be someone that you're not
you never want to potentially get sent
home not feeling like
you you want to be part of what you do
so i just walked into the show and was
like i'm going to give them just like
joey j head on and like
watch the feathers fly work this is a
once in a lifetime opportunity in candy
what wisdom did asha
impart on you or anyone else well right
before coming to drag queens azure
pretty much for me to be myself and have
a good time and just enjoy the ride
because it's gonna be a wild one
and just really you know bask in the
moment
take got your dollars [ __ ] on the flip
side here did you get any advice from
anyone that you went
i should not have taken that one any bad
advice going into this
i think so no no i don't think i did
everyone everyone steered me right
i got good sisters i ain't got shady
ones dahlia told me to go home first
girl what so um we'll see how that goes
it wasn't their fault because our season
is so unique but
basically the queen said that i should
come in in the most grand and epic
outfit that i had ever wanted to on
rupaul's drag race
because that's your entrance look you
know it is so important and so i did
um and uh yeah we had to live thinking
that so that was a little tough
who gave you that advice because that in
any other season that's good advice
you know it was it was naomi i love her
to death but she was like
[ __ ] make it your moment yeah
[Laughter]
and then you were up there lips and king
cursing i was like
told me do not shave your eyebrows i did
not listen to her
i shaved my eyebrows off and like so i
like fully regret it because i know i'm
like crazy in the confessional
but somebody should have warned me to uh
wear more makeup as a boy for the
confessionals
thank you